معنا من القصر الرئاسي في انقره مراسله
الجزيره فرح الزمان شوقي طبعا الاقتصاد
والتجاره هو العنوان الرئيس لهذه الزياره
التي تاجلت مرتين فرح لكن فلسطين حاضره في
كلمه
الرئيسين حضرت كذلك على الطاوله الثنائيه
التركيه الايرانيه بقوه في الحقيقه وهذا
واضح من تصريحات كلا الرئيسين واضح ان
الحرب على غزه كانت عنوان رئيسيا في هذه
الزياره المؤجله لمرتين الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يؤكد مره اخرى على الموقف
المتعلق بضروره وقف الحرب يؤكد ايضا على
ضروره اتخاذ خطوات تمهد لما وصفه بسلام
عادل وشامل يؤكد على ضروره ايصال
المساعدات ويؤكد ايضا على الدور الايراني
التركي الذي من الممكن ان يلعب دورا
اقليميا ودوليا وذلك بما يساهم بوقف الحرب
على غزه بال المقابل الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي يتحدث هنا كذلك عن ضروره
التعاون التركي الايراني ضروره وقف الحرب
ويندد وينتقد ما وصفه بدور بدور المنظمات
الدوليه التي تدعي الدفاع على عن حقوق
الانسان كما وصف وبالتالي هو يؤكد على
ضروره اتباع دور سياسي ثنائي تركي ايراني
بما يصب لصالح انهاء هذه الحرب هذا من
ناحيه ناحيه الحرب على غزه لكن النقطه
الثانيه المتعلقه ب مساله تجنيب المنطقه
للمزيد من الصراعات بحسب وصف الرئيس
التركي وبحسب ما جاء في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي واضح بان اردوغان نقل
لنظيره الايراني ضروره ان تلعب طهران دورا
في مساله تجنيب المنطقه لاي صراعات جديده
وهذا بسبب انها معنيه بشكل او باخر بما
يجري على الجبهه اللبنانيه او في سوريا او
في العراق او حتى في البحر الاحمر بالتالي
ركزت تركيا من جهاتها خلال هذ هذه
الاجتماعات على نقل هذه الرساله التركيه
لايران وفي المقابل يرد الرئيس الايراني
على على هذه التصريحات بالقول بان امن هذه
المنطقه هو امن ايران وهو امن تركيا
بالتالي ايران ايضا معنيه بحسب الرئيس
الايراني بعدم التصعيد او بعدم توسيع
دائره الصراع الاقليمي لذا بالتالي يحضر
ملف غزه اولا ثانيا ملف التصعيد في
المنطقه الى جانب ملفات العلاقات الثنائيه
ايضا نقطه اخيره تطرق اليها الطرفان وهي
المتعلقه بمساله مكافحه الارهاب يؤكد كلا
الطرفين على تفهم مخاوف الطرف الاخر في
الوقت الذي يعقد فيه اجتماع في استنه
يتعلق
بالملف السوري وفي الوقت الذي تستمر فيه
الضربات التركيه على الشمال السوري الرئيس
التركي معني ايضا ببحث هذا الملف مع نظيره
الايراني لا سما بوجود تفاهمات اي تركيا
مع كل من ايران وروسيا هي هامه للغايه
لتوضع في هذا السياق الى جانب توقيع
العديد من الاتفاقيات عشره اتفاقيات جديده
تتعلق بمجالات اقتصاديه